c'est vrai que c'est toute une époque
cette année sept années 70 c'est
l'arrivée des consoles qu'on appelait
pong qui sont des consoles multi je mets
tous les jeux se ressemblent et
embrouillé avait deux bars et c'est le
tennis le foot le hockey
pour 300 francs environ les prix ont
beaucoup baissé le petit écran se
transforme en terrain de football mon
court de tennis
les adversaires se renvoyant la balle
grâce à une commande manuelle le
journaliste est plutôt bienveillant
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup souffert de
du traitement par les médias du jeu
vidéo mais là ya pas encore le mal du
jeu vidéo qu'on a qu'on a subi gea dans
les années 80-90 la mâchoire et crispé
le regard fixe les gestes saccadés les
symptômes sont clairs le diagnostic sans
appel ces enfants sont atteints d'un mal
très contemporain la passion des jeux
vidéo il est il a essayé d'y fiancée
reportage n'avait jamais vu mais le
champ lexical du journalisme les le mal
les symptômes les plans sur les les yeux
le crisper etc enfin je veux dire on
voit déjà dans ce reportage tout l'écart
entre les médias et finalement le jeu
vidéo deux cent quarante mille consoles
vendues l'année dernière en france après
les états unis l'angleterre et
l'allemagne nous sommes donc atteinte
nous aussi par cette épidémie mais
d'autres personnes au contraire il voit
un côté bénéfique pour les jeunes avec
le jeu vidéo ils sont ils participent et
il participe avec patient et il ya une
espèce de compétition avec soi-même ils
veulent se vaincre même ils veulent
gagner ils veulent réussir et à partir
du moment où un enfant heures réussi
évidemment il ya un dynamisme absolument
extraordinaire qui ce qui existe en 8
mai map six colloques et quand même eu
déjà d'un certain âge à cette époque et
qui découvre le jeu vidéo un regard très
bienveillant et comprend que finalement
ça aide les enfants à se dépasser ce
alors à se fixer des objectifs etc et
pourtant les médias eux ne le voit pas
quarante ans plus tard l'image des jeux
vidéo à la télé a bien changé selon
bertrand amar aujourd'hui le traitement
qui fait du jeu vidéo par les médias et
je le trouve très juste on voit bien
aujourd'hui quand il ya une compétition
qui est organisé les médias viennent
salue la ferveur populaire le talent des
joueurs et c'est donc on a un traitement
qui est bienveillant mais surtout juste
les journalistes non plus les idées
préconçues qu'ils avaient à l'époque
[Musique]